one thing I'll leave you with is give
the piranha chance try to read it you
know ask God for guidance if you ask God
for guidance you will guide you okay
this is not good idea because we were
talking about the religion yeah actively
for your faith
[Music]
I shall open
that the whole
lady so high level feed the power
what then
are you religious you know sometimes but
especially you looks like you've been
through a lot of torture so you must you
must work especially with the callous
sometimes they believe it's something
you gotta believe every single day in
something okay you don't believe in
yourself for example he's not gonna get
anything in your life okay all right so
do you believe in a higher intelligence
you even got there okay but do you
believe
tell me give me a little description of
God do you believe is a man do you
believe but what is it you energy okay
okay so you believe in God but you
believe his energy yeah okay so what do
you mean by even more powerful than
anyone beyond okay yes he is more
powerful but when you say energy what do
you mean remove everything he knows how
him he knows everything
without without him without him yeah
nothing anymore
nothing to live nothing lives nothing
lives this could be but oh hey this is
this is this is we were Muslims yeah
we believe in toe heat so that's the
oneness of God yeah okay
so we don't believe God can be a man
this is not kind to dance right now this
second yes it's not positive it's not
going say it's a train because other
view believe if you see the father as
well that's good so even you don't
believe this is a coincidence yeah so
you believe that God is all-knowing
all-powerful do you believe that you
have a purpose exactly every single wife
has a purpose what's what's what's your
purpose always every single day you're
you know on the way and your step by
step you you have to take a look and
you don't know exactly where you gonna
go okay you're going somewhere okay so
do you think as human beings if there is
a higher intelligence we should be
grateful to him
maybe we should worship Him I'm trying
to get that are you thank you do you
have a connection with God
yeah of course every single day I pray
I'm a I'm a of meditation you do
meditation is very sad okay do you do
meditation for like for religious
reasons or it's just you know to get
your mind and body both but what about
so when you meditate what kind of
communication do you have we've got
Almighty
sometimes you gotta steps right the
first step say thanks to be thankful to
be right okay second thing is I say I'm
sorry for my mistakes we give her you
know are you sure you know Muslims
that's that's not the true Muslim the
third one is a unit something
please God I know I am NOT nothing
without these that's really powerful
I am not nothing to dull I am nothing
without you you know what those are -
essa T and you know what's my necessity
okay
stylist he'll mediate with me to get my
exactly this is one of the things Jesus
peace be upon him said in the Quran
verse well God Almighty asked me said
did you ask you and your you know some
Christians believe Jesus as God and his
mother he said did you tell them that
you and your mother are deities beside
me he said God Oh God oh Allah
you know what's inside me I don't know
what's inside you
so you thought all traits about like
Islam so for example when we communicate
we've got Almighty we pray five times a
day yeah
phyto if a very scary look can you look
into the camera too scared is the
critical might go viral
that's theory I'm trying to talk to
mommy notice my concentration is a bit
like so yeah anybody
yes we're named already yeah I put
asking me my name is Ali bhai yeah
Muhammad Ali yeah so basically when we
pray we say I would have been like him
in a shaytani regime that means we seek
refuge from the state I'm from from the
devil and we see who seek refuge in
Allah from the cursed Satan yeah yeah we
see I wouldn't be like 'no shaytan al
rajim bismillahi rahmani raheem for
Allah the most merciful the very
merciful yeah and they would say
al-hamdu lillahi rabbil alameen all
praises belong to the lord of the whole
world
yeah hamdu lillahi rabbil aalameen
r-rahmani r-rahim
yeah the merciful they're very merciful
rahmani raheem Malachy o me Dean the
owner of the Day of Judgment yeah so
believe he's the owner do you believe in
their judgement that one day were going
to be questioned by police somewhere
some babe you're gonna you know go to
the next life why did he don't gonna ask
me he cannot tell you whether this
quantity for the humans so what did you
do for the humans
in general we already did you know for
be a better person better father better
okay so we say Mele Kiyomi B so you are
the owner of the day of judgment
yeah can a boo do well yeah cannot stay
in you alone we worship and you alone we
ask for help so I remember when he said
he was doing meditation you said he's
the one that knows what I need and he's
the one you're asking for help yeah so
he yakin a buddha wa iyyaka nastain
Idina sirat al-mustaqim
guide us to the straight path yeah
God is the straight path Dena sirat
al-mustaqim sirata al-ladhina an AMTA
alayhim
hi real must obey Him what a darling
guide us to the straight path the path
of those you've bestowed your blessing
on not of those who have earned your
anger or those who have gone astray yet
so basically this is what we ask so we
ask Allah Almighty to make us among
those who
ship him and him alone yeah yeah perhaps
right there yeah yeah yeah you need to
charge them this is not free have you
have you have you so you believe in God
Almighty yeah you don't believe he's a
human never give me one coconut
yeah so you believe in God do you
believe you don't give goodies that come
on yeah
you don't believe is that a man do you
believe God to me a man like a many do
you think God can become a man it's
something bigger that the universe is
something bigger than that you know
they're all the galaxies v he created
everything yes so he can't be in his
creation exactly just hungry the oneness
so have you read the Quran before your
religion iMac italic you'll know it
yeah oh okay all right and I respect
every single you know relieve you yeah
and I guess those are different point of
views yeah I'm not saying mine is
correct yes correct
yeah I guess the only commune sense that
every single relieve you have to get
this big deal with yourself and be with
your with the world okay and be the best
that you can do for you and for the
people around all there are all the
people that dis around you okay so
what's your take on Mary the mother of
Jesus that do you see her as a divine
being that do you worship to an all
divine if not by mother are mark Murray
yeah Maria Maria not he's the mother of
God
she's mother is just the body she okay
he was the other body okay right so I
believe in that because my controlling
religion is they treat you that and I
believe you there okay so maybe he's
wrong maybe the history they changes me
about that what I think that that I you
know I respect that
but logically do you think it makes
sense that God has a mother
but the like I respect all ways you can
be careful condition question I remember
in the cat rally and cat alley
yeah that's God Father God son Great God
yes right those are three in one
right so happy I am like I told you it
every single religion is it's similar
different a big difference
the for example baby the Christians they
don't believe in Maria right they don't
believe in yeah in other Saints yes
alright so they um you know if okay so
why don't you give the piranha chance
like why don't you read it one day you
know because I didn't they you know
you're here for you got one life
eventually was going to ask you there is
a lots of religious okay but one must be
the truth there must be one that is the
truth and as Muslims we believe in Jesus
we believe in his miraculous birth we
believe in his mother there's a whole
chapter in the Quran called surah Maryam
Mary yeah so the issue is what would you
say this is that you should look into it
because God's gonna question you and say
look this was the right path wherever it
may be and you should look into it so I
would personally say to you obviously I
know you're working I don't want to hold
you too much yeah so I don't believe but
you know and then I guess
but but like I then I guess she don't
gotta relieve you keep that time yes we
don't think which one is the correct
everyone gonna say this is better but
there must be one judge the Catholics
everyone say this is the correct way yes
but everyone everyone can say that but
there must be one that must be the truth
it's not with me I looked into
Christianity I looked into Judaism I
became a Muslim five six years ago yeah
so I didn't look into variety of
religions one thing I'll leave you with
is give the piranha chance try to read
it you know ask God for guidance if you
ask God for guidance you will guide you
you know is anything else you won't ask
me anything else you won't ask me I see
thank you much I really appreciate her
but God guides you and myself as well
can you do me a favor and just do what
you did with that knife and we take a
little her picture here okay this is not
good idea because we were talking about
your face